bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler d'un paradoxe de
statistiques qu'on appelle le paradoxe
de simpson
si vous connaissez pas ce paradoxe je
vous promets que vous allez trouver
vraiment perturbant et une fois que vous
aurez vu la vidéo
je suis sûr que vous regarderez plus les
chiffres de la même manière quand on
vous montrent des statistiques
voilà imaginons vous êtes à l'hôpital et
vous venez de passer des examens
et puis là pas de bol bas il s'avère que
vous avez un truc bizarre qui se révèle
être une tumeur alors le médecin vous
reçoit et puis vous explique qu'il faut
la soigner et il vous dit que pour ça il
existe deux types de traitements le
premier type de traitement c'est
d'utiliser des médicaments donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la chimiothérapie et
puis l'autre type de traitement c'est de
faire une chirurgie et puis là le
médecin vous demande lequel de
traitement vous voulez suivre alors à
priori vous y connaissez pas grand chose
donc voulu poser la question qu'on a
tous envie de se poser dans ce genre de
situation c'est à dire c'est lequel des
deux traitements qui marche le mieux
et alors là le médecin vous sort les
chiffres d'une étude statistique qui a
été fait au niveau national et qui
recense les taux de guérison des 1000
derniers patients qui ont été traités
avec chacune des deux techniques alors
les chiffres les voici dans le cas des
médicaments le taux de guérison a été de
76 % et dans le cas de la chirurgie il a
été un peu moins élevé il a été de
seulement 66%
bon donc la sphère paraît clair les
médicaments marche un peu mieux donc
vous décidez de partir sur un traitement
à base de médicaments
et puis quelques jours plus tard vous
rencontré votre médecin traitant et il a
pas l'air tout à fait d'accord avec
votre choix et ils vous expliquent qu'en
fait ça dépend de la taille de la tumeur
alors ils cherchent dans ses papiers et
il retrouve une étude qui montre les
taux de guérison mais séparés par taille
des tumeurs alors voici les chiffres
pour les grosses tumeurs qu'on définit
comme étant celles de plus de 2 cm
le taux de guérison des médicaments et
de 49 pour cent celui de la chirurgie il
est de 63% donc sur les grosses tumeurs
c'est la chirurgie qui marche le mieux
et puis sur les petites tumeurs
le taux de guérison des médicaments et
de 82 % et celui de la chirurgie de 90%
donc sur les petites tumeurs c'est aussi
la chirurgie qui marche le mieux mon
oncle à vous êtes complètement perdus
est ce que vous avez une étude qui vous
dit que les médicaments marche mieux et
une autre étude qui vous dit que c'est
toujours la chirurgie qui marche le
mieux alors vous prenez les deux études
vous les comparez vous essayez de
comprendre c'est quoi la différence
et puis soudain vous réalisez que en
fait ces chiffres ne forment qu'une
seule et même étude ce sont exactement
les mêmes chiffres
je vais vous montrer donc ici je vous ai
remis les chiffres
de la deuxième étude donc on sépare par
taille de tumeurs et vous voyez je
voulais pas seulement les taux de
guérison je vous mets aussi à chaque
fois combien de patients ont été traités
comme ça et si on fait le total du
nombre de patients qui ont été traités
par médicament
eh ben on retrouve le chiffre que je
vous ai donné tout à l'heure et le taux
de guérison et 76% et si vous faites la
somme des chiffres des patients qui ont
été traités par chirurgie bas vous
retrouvez aussi le chiffre que je vous
ai donné et avec un taux de guérison de
66%
donc si vous ne croyez pas je vous
conseille de revenir un petit peu en
arrière et vous pouvez vérifier mes
calculs on voit bien que au global les
médicaments ont un taux de guérison
meilleur mais si on sépare par types de
tumeurs c'est la chirurgie qui a
toujours un taux de guérison meilleur
bon donc là normalement vous demandez
comment c'est possible comment est-ce
qu'en partant des mêmes chiffres
je peux au global conclure que les
médicaments marche le mieux
mais sur chaque type de tumeur prises
individuellement conclure que c'est la
chirurgie qui marche le mieux
alors je vous rassure il n'y a pas
d'erreur il n'y a pas de manipulation
n'y a pas de trucs
ce que vous voyez là c'est juste les
vrais chiffres et vous êtes face à ce
paradoxe de statistiques qu'on appelle
le paradoxe de simpson et c'est un
paradoxe qui dit que certaines données
statistiques
suivant la manière dont on les analyse
on peut aboutir à une conclusion ou à la
conclusion opposée
donc là le problème c'est que vous avez
vraiment envie de savoir quels
traitements marche le mieux
est ce que c'est les médicaments est ce
que c'est la chirurgie est ce qu'il faut
croire la première manière de présenter
les choses
ou plutôt la deuxième je vous laisse
vous faire votre opinion pendant une
seconde et puis je vous donner la
réponse
en fait la vérité c'est que c'est la
chirurgie qui marche le mieux le fait
que les médicaments et l'air d'avoir des
taux de guérison plus élevé en moyenne
c'est juste une apparence pour
comprendre ça il faut retourner dans le
détail des chiffres il ya deux
observations importantes à faire la
première c'est que les grosses tumeurs
ont des taux de guérison plus faible que
les petites tumeurs 11 pas très
surprenant on imagine que les grosses
tumeurs sont plus difficiles à guérir
mais la deuxième observation importante
c'est que quand on a une grosse tumeur
on utilise beaucoup plus souvent la
chirurgie que les médicaments
donc qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
intrinsèquement la chirurgie fonctionne
mieux
sauf que historiquement dès qu'on a eu
un cas difficile on a beaucoup plus
souvent utilisé la chirurgie que les
médicaments donc sur les données
statistiques quand on regarde tout ça le
score de la chirurgie il est moins élevé
parce qu'on lui a toujours filer les cas
difficiles pour comprendre comment ça
peut se produire ce genre de situation
au niveau statistique
il faut faire appel à une notion qu'on
appelle le facteur de confusion
qu'est ce qu'on essaye de faire ici on
essaie d'étudier un lien de cause à
effet entre le choix du traitement et la
guérison alors la probabilité de
guérison
elle dépend du choix du traitement mais
elle dépend bien sûr de tout un tas de
facteurs et notamment de la taille de la
tumeur
sauf que dans les données qu'on utilise
la taille de la tumeur a aussi joué sur
les choix des traitements qu'on a
utilisé vous souvenez à chaque fois
qu'on avait des grosses tumeurs on avait
plutôt tendance à utiliser la chirurgie
que les médicaments et donc on a un
facteur externe
la taille de la tumeur qui joue à la
fois sur la conséquence mais aussi sur
la cause qu'on veut étudier et donc
c'est ça qu'on appelle un facteur de
confusion et c'est quand on est dans ce
genre de situation que le paradoxe de
simpson peut se produire alors qu'on
vient vous faire comprendre ça je vais
prendre un exemple qui est peut-être un
petit peu caricatural mais qui est
intéressant un jour j'ai écouté un débat
à la radio sur les bienfaits ou pas du
redoublement est l'un des deux
protagonistes disait la chose suivante
il disait le redoublement
ça sert à rien la preuve les élèves qui
ont redoublé pendant leur scolarité au
final au bac
ils ont des notes moins bonne que les
autres alors je veux bien croire que la
question des bienfaits du redoublement
soit compliqué mais ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que cet argument il est stupide
je pense que vous voyez pourquoi les
élèves qu'on fait redoubler en général
c'est ceux qui sont en difficulté
scolaire
donc ce n'est pas hyper surprenant de
constater que à la fin ces élèves là ils
ont des notes moins bonne que les autres
bacs et si vous regardez finement le
truc vous voyez que on est aussi dans
une situation où on a un facteur de
confusion ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
d'étudier le lien de cause à effet entre
le fait de redoubler ou pas et les notes
au bac et on a un facteur qui est le
niveau scolaire de l'élève qui va jouer
sur ses notes au bac mais qui va aussi
jouer sur le fait qu'on ait choisi de
faire redoubler ou pas
donc le niveau scolaire de l'élève est
un facteur de confusion
et si on l'oubli eh ben on aboutit à une
conclusion qui est erronée au plan
statistique qui est que faire redoubler
les élèves ça fait baisser leur note au
bac
alors pour bien montrer que les facteurs
de confusion et donc le paradoxe de
simpson peuvent se cacher un petit peu
partout dans les statistiques je vais
prendre encore un autre exemple
imaginons que vous vouliez étudié le
lien qui existe entre la consommation de
bière des gens et leur libido
alors qu'est ce que vous faites vous
prenez un échantillon représentatif de
la population
et puis vous leur soumettait un
questionnaire où ils doivent évaluer
leur consommation hebdomadaire de bière
et puis notez leur libido sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 très bien vous
distribuez le questionnaire vous
récupérez les réponses vous analyser les
données et puis vous décidez de faire un
graphique qui va montrer la libido en
fonction la consommation de bière donc
sur ce graphique chaque point représente
une des personnes que vous avez
interrogé et montre sa consommation
guerre et sa libido et donc qu'est ce
qu'on voit sur ce graphique et ben on
voit qui semble y avoir une belle
corrélation entre les deux c'est à dire
que plus on boit des bières plus on a
une libido élevé donc la super vous
préparer à faire un communiqué de presse
avec kronenbourg et soudain quelqu'un
vous demande qu'est ce qui se passe si
on regarde quels sont les hommes et
qu'elles sont les femmes sur ce
graphique alors vous reprenez vos
données et puis vous retracer le
graphique en coloriant différemment les
hommes et les femmes et la voilà ce que
vous obtenez en fait vous voyez que chez
les femmes
la consommation de bière a pas
franchement en influence sur la libido
même plutôt une influence négative
et puis chez les hommes eh ben il n'y a
pas vraiment en influence non plus vous
voyez que si on différencie par sexe en
fait il n'ya pas du tout de corrélation
entre la consommation de bière et la
libido et pourtant si on oublie de
regarder sa différence et par sexe on a
l'impression qu'à une corrélation est
donc on est encore une fois dans
exactement le même genre de situation
c'est à dire qu'on essaie de étudié le
lien de cause à effet entre consommation
de bière et libido et on a un facteur de
confusion qui est le sexe des gens qui
jouent à la fois sur la consommation de
bière parce que les hommes ont tendance
à avoir plus de bière et sur leur libido
parce que les hommes ont tendance à voir
une vidéo plus élevé alors je vous
rassure ça c'est une étude fictives
c'est moi qui ai inventé les chiffres
mais des situations de ce genre là je
vous promets qu'il en existe partout
voilà j'espère vous avoir convaincus que
le paradoxe de simpson peut se cacher un
peu partout et donc qu'il faut toujours
être méfiant quand on regarde les
statistiques et maintenant la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
pouvoir se
munir de ce paradoxe alors il existe que
deux solutions la première méthode c'est
il faut savoir qui est un facteur de
confusion
il faut y avoir pensé et il faut
analyser les données en conséquence
c'est ce qu'on a fait par exemple dans
le cas de la tumeur ou on a analysé les
données par taille de tumeurs et c'est
ce qu'on a fait aussi dans le cas de la
bière et les libidos où on a différencié
l'analyse par sexe mais ça c'est pas
évident parce que il faut connaître le
facteur de confusion alors par exemple
dans mon cas du redoublement c'était un
petit peu évident je pense que tout le
monde avait senti le piège dans le cas
de la bière et de la libido c'était
beaucoup moins évident de penser aux
facteurs de confusion
et puis alors dans le cas des tumeurs si
vous n'êtes pas un spécialiste du sujet
il n'y a aucune chance que vous y
pensiez donc est ce que ça nous montre
ça ça nous montre que quand on regarde
les statistiques on peut pas se passer
d'avoir quelqu'un qui sait de quoi il
parle qui connaît le domaine dont il est
question et ça je pense que c'est une
leçon importante parce que vous savez à
l'heure des big data de l'open data
on a l'impression qu'il ya plein de
données disponibles partout et puis que
n'importe qui peut aller piocher des
données les analyser et puis tirer des
conclusions et ben en fait non c'est pas
vrai on ne peut pas se passer de
quelqu'un qui sait de quoi il parle
l'autre option pour être sûr de ne pas
tomber dans le paradoxe de simpson c'est
de faire une expérience dans tous les
exemples dont je vous ai parlé à chaque
fois on utilise des données qui existe
déjà
c'est ce qu'on appelle une étude
rétrospective alors que si on crée de
toutes pièces une expérience dont on va
analyser les données
on fait ce qu'on appelle une étude
prospective c'est quoi la différence
je vous ai dit un facteur de confusion
il pose problème parce que ils influent
à la fois sur la cause et la conséquence
qu'on souhaite étudier
donc la solution c'est de casser le lien
entre le facteur de confusion est la
cause on va prendre un exemple si je
reviens sur le cas du redoublement
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
prouver à coup sûr si le redoublement
c'est efficace ou pas mais parce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est prendre une classe
l'a coupé en deux au hasard et dire la
première moitié de la faire doubler et
la deuxième moitié
je la fais passer si on fait ça dans
chacun des deux groupes
on aura des élèves de tous les niveaux
et donc à la fin en comparant les notes
au bac de ces deux groupes
on pourra savoir s'il ya vraiment un
impact positif du redoublement sur les
notes au bac
vous voyez que le problème de ce genre
de choses c'est que faire une expérience
comme ça ça peut être très compliqué ça
peut être très long ça peut poser des
problèmes d'éthique mais pourtant c'est
le seul moyen de prouver à coup sûr un
lien entre une cause et un effet et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que quand on
développe un nouveau médicament un
moment donné pour prouver l'efficacité
du médicament on doit toujours faire une
étude prospective et c'est pour ça que
développer un nouveau médicament ça
coûte cher et ça prend du temps parce
qu'il ya toujours des tests très long à
faire mais qui sont absolument
nécessaires pour être sûr de se prémunir
de tous les effets des facteurs de
confusion
alors j'espère vous avoir convaincu
qu'il faut toujours se méfier des
statistiques mais qu'il faut s'en méfier
de manière intelligente
c'est à dire que quand tout vous
montrent des chiffres il faut toujours
vous vous demandiez si ces chiffres ils
viennent d'une étude rétrospective c'est
à dire qu'on a analysé des chiffres
existants ou si ils viennent d'une étude
prospective on l'a fait une expérience
s'ils viennent d'une étude rétrospective
il faut faire attention il peut y avoir
des facteurs de confusion on les connaît
pas forcément et on peut conclure des
choses qui sont complètement fausses par
contre si c'est une étude de prospective
alors là il ya un peu plus de chance que
ce soit du solide à titre d'exercice on
peut se demander ce que ça donnerait de
faire une étude prospective dans mon cas
de la bière et de la libido et ben
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
il faudrait prendre un groupe de
personnes alors par exemple vous et puis
il faudrait chaque personne lui attribué
au hasard un niveau de consommation de
bière donc par exemple ça vous intéresse
vous inscrivez en commentaire moi je
vous donne au hasard un niveau de
consommation de bière compris entre
mettons 0 et vins bières par semaine
vous vous y tenez pendant un mois
et au bout d'un mois vous notez votre
vidéo sur une échelle de 1 à 10 hélas
comme ça on aura éliminé tous les
facteurs de confusion et on saura
vraiment si la consommation de bière a
une influence sur la libido
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu vous pouvez m'aider à
faire connaître la chaîne en partageant
la vidéo vous pouvez aussi bien sûr vous
abonner me retrouver sur facebook sur
twitter et aussi sur mon blog sciences
étonnante
merci à bientôt
oh